I think our first sip of coffee today oh
nice
nice one that's the best one you never
get that one again you know what I mean
yeah it's that first
steps I would say having known you for
very long you don't slip as much as you
slurp there you go Glenn doesn't sip as
much as you slurp I do tend to sleep I
admit that I am a slurper you're right
you're totally right and it's so
hypocritical too because I hate mouth
noises so much and I recognize that you
know what a slurp isn't half as bad as a
chew or I mean by the way I am a girl a
girl a gulp can be oh like a loud super
loud how about yeah smacking after you
eat where you're like like that yeah
I don't want to hear your satisfied I
want to know how satisfied you are
fighting be fine to hear someone like
growing like eat some people like oh
that wouldn't bother you going right
gotta go they go it's just yeah you're
just like don't shove your satisfaction
in my face I'm trying to enjoy my own
meal if you want to show me the rest of
us if you want to show me how upset you
are with what you're eating that's fine
because I'm enjoying my food and now I
know in relation to you I'm happier a
smack of disgust you know
but that doesn't bother you that was a
bag of joy
[Applause]
it's really that you don't want other
people to be happy that's what we're
getting is that what we have oh I mean
you can break it down to all sorts of
things it's probably cool well I I
actually did go to a hypnotherapist
about this at one point and he actually
this oh no actually no I went to a
hypnotherapist and a regular therapist
uh the regular it was just about you
know all kinds of things but the
hypnotherapist specifically I went to
you know to deal with the whole like is
there a way that um because this guy had
it was like it was actually Jimmy's guy
Jimmy this guy Jimmy stuff that was a
gulp did anybody week after that oh I go
I have a I have a loud throat noise that
was a guy I think it bothers me
interesting now it didn't bother me I
wouldn't have thought about it except
that you just now I talked about it the
whole time I have to cut all the girls
I have to I have to think that we caught
that sorry I don't know uh anyway you
caught it
so anyway I went to this guy and you
know he had a pretty good reputation and
and I was like look this is my situation
can you help me with it I I just it
really bugs me when people smack their
gum when people when I can hear people
chewing their food especially when
they're smacking
you say yeah I can help you with that
you know he hypnotized me nothing
happened I mean as far as I could tell
like I was like you know he just like
you're in an elevator and you're gonna
start him I'm gonna start counting down
from this and I was like okay this is
interesting because I don't see how this
would do anything and then inside the
bowl of cereal he's like well wait a
minute actually I'm really sleepy you're
so slippy okay you're joking but that's
exactly what he did I am not kidding you
as he was putting me under he had a
glass of water
and he would go and he would be like
and we're going down for we're on floor
50. 49
.
and you're on 48.
maybe he was it intentional or was it I
think it was intentional but you paid
him for that but maybe he programmed
slurping into your brain and that's why
you slurp
no no for years I think I've been
slipping for a long time that's what he
has programmed your brain to believe I
remember it was also it was like a blue
plastic cup I don't know why I remember
there did he even accept it I don't know
but it but it was it was crazy and I
remember thinking like well this is just
really [ __ ] irritating and I don't
feel hypnotized in the slightest bit you
were irritated
I was irritated
guys I'm coming in hot today
and it's not about slurping and mouth
noises okay I had a crazy crazy day uh a
night and day Friday night and Saturday
the kind of thing that sent me into uh a
rage
but then something happened at a certain
point where I just surrendered to the
situation
and then all sorts of life lessons crept
in over the course of the time that I
was going through this ordeal okay so
here's what happened
so uh earlier in the day on Friday my
key fob on my car so I drive a Tesla
I drive a Tesla Model X okay the key fob
stopped working on my car okay that's
okay you can use the app on your phone
to drive your car okay so I was like
okay that's a good Fail-Safe that works
so I'm driving around it's all good uh I
go to pick up my buddy Nick Wexler
because we're going to a screening at
the DGA of a friend's uh uh uh a new
show that he's made so we go to the DGA
I parked the DGA is uh the Director's
Guild yes I'm sorry yeah the Director's
Guild of America yeah yeah and sometimes
they do screenings and things like this
so we went to a screening
I park in the bottom floor of the
parking garage you can probably already
see where I'm going with this now in
order for the app
on the phone to work you need to have
internet connection on your phone
and the car
the phone does not speak directly to the
cart now I can Bluetooth music from the
phone to the car but I can't control the
car through the Bluetooth so I've so we
get down to the car
and my key fob is not working and I
can't connect to the internet and I'm
suddenly I'm like
okay there's got to be a solution to
this but this is wild I can't I I don't
know what I'm supposed to do here and I
was like
maybe I just need to go get a new
battery for the key fob so I went to get
a new battery so we walk over the right
get a new battery for key fob but I was
like but
there's supposed to be an indicator that
says you've got low battery you know so
anyway put a new battery in still didn't
work
couldn't figure out how to get my car
out of there was like I guess I'll just
Uber home so I just ubered home left the
car there told security I was like I put
a note on my car please don't tow my car
I go back to DJ that morning as early as
possible
the second I arrive everything the whole
building is taped off as if there was a
bomb threat or something and I'm like
this is crazy like at every step of the
way throughout this whole story every
single thing that could go wrong went
wrong nobody would tell me what was
going on finally I got the supervisor's
attention he got the security guard I
was able to go in turns out they were
just doing construction on the roof okay
all good oh sorry I figured out a way
the night before that there is a way you
can get in the car without the battery
on the key fob working using the chip
you can put it on a certain place in the
car and the door will open then once you
get inside you can put it on a place in
a certain place inside and the car will
start it's like oh that's a good
Fail-Safe so if your fob's not working
and you don't have access to the
internet there is a way to open the car
and to start it because I couldn't even
open the car the night before so I did
the thing car door opened I'm like oh
yes okay sweet put the thing where it's
supposed to go to start the car wouldn't
start
moving around tried this for about 20
minutes wouldn't start I was like this
is unbelievable so I was like okay fine
take us there though take us there at
that moment when you when you did that
can you reenact that that moment I just
want to see I want to feel it I want to
because there was you screamed I
screamed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I can
imagine I can imagine this moment when
it when when the key fob got to the mo
and you looked and it didn't start uh
can we take us there was your car also
the only one now in the parking lot yeah
so he's alone it was a Saturday it was a
Saturday so the whole parking garage was
like completely empty also by the way I
can't be on the phone with Tesla
troubleshooting because I don't have
reception
okay we'll get to that uh so do you
remember what you screamed was it just
fine yeah okay yeah just a big like
like just like and then once I got that
out I was like okay so then I I'm trying
all these different spots to try to get
it to work can't get it to work I'm like
this is unfucking believable so I was
like all right I'm just gonna put the
car in tow mode
and or no I'm just gonna go call AAA and
and now that I know I can get in the car
I know I can put it in tow mode so I'll
go call AAA call AAA
they're like what's the what is the
clearance of the parking garage
and I was like I don't know and I asked
security guard he's like six and a half
feet and he was like oof
that's that's really low
um we only have a few trucks that can do
that let me see what we can do right so
they did actually find one that was low
enough that that they could dispatch out
and get out there so I go down to the
garage to put the car in tow mode the
car won't go in tow mode The Screen
Works everything works I'm doing
everything right the Carson Park it says
your car has to be in parked you got to
put have your foot on the brake for the
car to go in tow mode but it's grayed
out no matter what I do it's grayed out
I can't I don't want to derail a story
but like no please do [ __ ] keys man
like yeah what was wrong it was a great
system they put it in the thing and you
turned it and then the car went and like
my wife's got a got a key fob right or
she operates everything with the key fob
but if every if all else fails there's a
little key that slides out of the fob
that you can use to open the door and
you can pull off the start stop button
sure and there's a key thing behind it I
one time put the TV on my house on like
an app on my phone and then you know
like the Wi-Fi would go off on your
phone and then you couldn't control the
TV and it was just a fiasco right and
then I had the guy come to the house to
be like hey can we get this off the
phone and I just want to go back to a
remote I can hold my hand and guy's like
sure he's like you know if you want I
could actually put all the lights on
your house on an app on your phone and I
was like he's like for nine million
dollars whatever yeah I'm like first of
all man that would be my version of a
nightmare I love that there's a switch
on the wall I pushed it down the light
goes on I push it down the light goes
off it's a little dimmer that's about as
fancy as I want to get with the light
switch you're 100 right by the way
because I didn't do that in my house and
I wish I did yeah there's certain things
that we just don't need to improve upon
yeah light switches keys well those are
time tested thousands of years yeah
that's right that's right yeah I know
sometimes analog really is better so
listener and creep you don't want to be
rich you don't want to be it's not that
great as we as we can that's exactly
it's better to just have your Ford
Taurus with the you know don't worry
about what questions well no even though
it doesn't matter it's just the cheapest
economy car they're probably making
still probably doesn't have a key and a
turn to everything's like a button yeah
but but most cars have a backup key in
the fob or whatever like there's some
and their backup system is it just reads
the chip well what happens when the fob
malfunctions because when I tell you
everything went wrong I mean everything
went wrong I got a new battery for the
fob and it didn't work
then I discovered it's not really the
battery there's something wrong like the
fob's not talking to the car so now
there's literally no way for me to get
my car out of there so I'm like I gotta
tow it car won't go in tow mode I'm
going to run at one point did you like
I'm realizing I have my key here my fob
here at one point did you hold were you
screaming at the phone no no I didn't
scream at the [ __ ] are you sure because
I think I would I think
you would write this for Dennis the the
Rams would be really great it would be
probably insufferable let's do that
let's not even talk about it let's do an
episode where Dennis gets a new car yes
an electric car yeah we're doing this
okay uh I think this this being like the
totem for the car and and having a
relationship with this is really the
whole episode with just me stuck in a
parking garage
you were just screaming insufferable and
trying to say technology but not being
able to get through the word technology
back to insufferable
like uh like insufferable no sufferable
like that would be a good tennis this
will be something that you write because
this is your specialty
sufferable yeah well I mean that is what
happened I mean technology completely
and totally failed me and then and then
Tesla roadside uh failed me and then
Tesla vehicle support failed me I was on
the phone with these people from 9 30 in
the morning until uh six o'clock at
night what trying to figure this out I
probably spoke to 12p people over at
Tesla everybody from roadside would then
be like well we can't and then they
would send me to vehicle support then
they would send me to roadside and I
would go back and forth and back and
forth they can just send you a guy with
a Charged Up fob to
nope that's not a thing that's what I
said I that's what I said to find by the
way I also had a very difficult time
getting through to any of these people
so finally I called sales and I'll say
this [ __ ] I hear you but you are
not getting through to me
all right right uh but I was like you
know you know who is going to pick up
the phone someone in sales and that was
exactly right that's exactly what
happened within two minutes I was on the
phone with somebody from sales uh lacing
into this guy and I was like you guys
lost a customer today I've been I've
been a Tesla customer for 10 years you
lost a customer today this is [ __ ] up
and I was like I don't mean to berate
you I know it's not your fault but you
guys have got to fix this because this
is crazy I can't get my car out of a
parking garage you know and and and the
technicians that I was speaking to on
the phone we would get I would get
through the whole explanation they would
ask they would troubleshoot with me I'd
be like tried it tried it tried it tried
it we would get to the end of the call
and they'd go
well I guess there's nothing we can do
and I'd be like
what do you mean there's nothing you can
do sir you chose to park your car in a
garage I'll say I caught you at a Moment
of Zen though because I spoke to you
midday Saturday yeah I got to a real
happy place and I'm not even kidding
yeah I got to an amazing amazing place I
really he was telling me the story he
was like he was laughing as he was
saying yeah yeah and this was by the way
probably five hours in my car had been
stuck there since the night before what
time did we talk around midday midday
maybe like one o'clock in the afternoon
something like that right so I'd been
I'd been at the D I'd been at the in
this building like basically I'm friends
with everybody in security all the
construction guys outside everybody's
mind they're all laughing at you they're
the other buds of mine well you know
it's a [ __ ] big ass no no no no
actually one of the guys his name was
Eddie I remember him he was one of the
construction guys and he had a model
three so he had a Tesla and he was like
let me help you figure this out by the
way this is this is this is one of the
things that got me to a very Zen Place
technology completely failed me okay but
Humanity completely saved me to a person
almost every single person that I
encountered
uh I wasn't even asking for their help I
was just asking for their patience I was
like I've got to get this car out I know
that it's in a tow away spot whatever
like just everybody was so nice so
helpful so kind so accommodating
it was
I didn't know people were still like
that what's the resolution
as far as we know the car is still there
I abandoned it again I went home again
now I had this this car is like
completely across town from where I live
right so that's the other thing too is
I've called people from Tesla from my
house and they'd be like are you with
the car now and I'd be like
nope
uh well uh it's gonna be hard to
troubleshoot with you with you not near
the car and I'm like
I can't wait I'm gonna kill somebody I
gotta kill someone it's not you because
I don't know how to get to you someone's
gonna die today if you can't help me
fall I'll figure this out
um so humanity is beautiful but you also
want to kind of snuff it out yeah yeah I
snuff a little bit of it out finally I
spoke to a woman who said I do know a
tow truck company that has a tow truck
that's low enough to get in that garage
and he can jack it up put it on put your
wheels on two wheels not on a flatbed
but there's this this is like bar that
they put under it so your wheels are
actually sitting on the bar and now
there's Wheels and that is eventually
what happened at 9 30 at night I'd been
there from 9 30 in the morning basically
until 9 30 at night with a little break
in between where I went home I had
didn't eat a meal the entire [ __ ] day
by the way I had I was yeah
um you were fasting I was fasting you
may be said hartha
who may be the Buddha you may have just
gone through transformation interesting
um yeah I it was it was enlightening and
uh and
yeah eventually I did get the car towed
out of there was able to use the app the
fob still doesn't work I told my son
yesterday we were driving around I was
like please don't let me park in a
parking garage because that is
absolutely something I would do oh no
absolutely without a doubt 100 I am the
type of person that would completely
forget like the second that all was
behind me I was like I was like my car
were I'm so grateful that I could
absolutely see myself Going Underground
in a parking garage and being like Oh my
god well that should be an option
like yeah parking in a parking garage
should be an option
I gotta get the phone yeah I gotta get
the fob fixed anyway so that's me coming
in hot but also me coming in enlightened
me coming in uh with a certain feeling
of surrender yeah
and uh rich guy Moment of Zen yeah yeah
you know listen I I I'm just gonna go
ahead and move past the fact that I'm
not allowed to complain about everything
because that's what this whole thing is
that's right you live your life and you
know you got to be able to you just
gotta be able to gripe if you can't
complain about your Tesla boy
well that's the thing well by the way we
could complain about our television show
which is what about this whole podcast
can I just and I we will get back to
that but I I will say that was the other
moment of surrender that was not just
faith and Humanity restored but it was
also realizing and this was actually the
first moment that I had was I was like
I I am so fortunate as a human being and
I'm so grateful for the wonderful
friends and family that I have
um and the resources that I have
the fact that I get to work in a
profession that I love I'm
extraordinarily fortunate and that but I
think that's what makes the you your
rant or a situation where you get into
like basically this this whole story I
think it what makes it fun and funny to
us certainly to me is that I know you
have that perspective so I know that
because otherwise you just be I have
that gear that's that's actually you
have that gear sure but you also have
the perspective like basically what you
what you just said you have gratitude
and understanding of like how ridiculous
it might be so yeah and if you didn't
then you'd just be like a miserable [ __ ]
but you're not and so yeah yeah right so
so but so when you find yourself in
[ __ ] uh in a in a [ __ ] mood it's
really funny yeah right right right yeah
oh I see that's you're it's you're
saying yeah it's it's it's funny because
because it's not ultimately who I am
that's not who you are because you have
enough awareness yeah yeah yes and then
you have the self-loathing and guilt
that comes that's associated with
feeling those things yeah because you
recognize all the things I wish I just
wish I do wish I could be calmer even in
the like I wish I never even had to I'd
love to get to a place where I didn't
even have to scream and get angry but
just be like just immediately be able to
surrender and just be like okay there's
a fix to this and this might take some
time and we're just gonna we're gonna
figure it out but there's nothing I
could do I'm not in control
life is good but that is what
enlightenment is that is that ain't
funny
the food ain't funny he's Jolly he's
kind of funny he's funny looking he's
back
yeah
he's not doing a setup at the store on
Saturday night
yeah that would be funny I would love to
see like a hardcore enlightened Buddha
Buddhist
set at The Comedy Store yeah you know
what I mean what would that be what
would that be that's a good bit to try
and somebody needs to do that sketch I'm
not a sketch writer but uh I'd like to
add a light and Buddha stand up set yeah
yeah I don't know how do you how can you
I don't know enough about Buddhism to uh
subvert things and you know like I I I
know very little I know I don't know
maybe like you guys know suffering you
know you got no suffering you know
everyone suffers right you gotta suffer
um
fine thing right so I'm suffering the
other day and I realized
you know I'm saying to myself wait a
second if I just like don't fight it
is that enlightened and that would be
like his cash flow oh that's his
catchphrase yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
what if he's got the catchphrase of uh
you know if you're if you're a Tesla
um won't start in a parking garage and
you don't get angry you might be a
Buddhist sure he's got a Jeff Fox but
he's got a Jeff foxer yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah how's everybody doing tonight
just want to start with I don't need
your laughter I hope you do laugh
because laughing will bring you Joy but
if you don't it matters not to me Joe
and Payne are equal size the same coin
you know what I'm talking about
this guy and this guy knows this guy
gets it
[Music]
we're now going to take a moment out of
this podcast to talk about some real
[ __ ] oh ship with a p yeah of course
we're talking about ship station which
integrates with every online platform to
manage all your shipping from one simple
dashboard it's uh it's an absolutely
invaluable tool to maximize sales and
save time with minimal effort remember
in season 15 when Charlie and D are
losing their minds with orders for
garments environments well think what a
helping hand like ship station would
provide for their business ah that would
have been huge join over 130 000
companies who have grown their
e-commerce business with ship station 98
of which become customers for life after
using it for a year I mean there's
there's tons of great names in there
including one of my personal faves siete
foods have you guys had that because
that's good ship so ship more and grow
more with ship station go to
shipstation.com today and sign up with
promo code Sunny for a free 60-day trial
Rob's right
start today and get set up before the
biggest shipping season of the year
that's two months free two are you
hearing me two months for free visit
shiftstation.com that's shipped with a p
.shiftstation.com Click the microphone
at the top and type in code Sunny so
whether you're starting small or you're
scaling up ship station makes ship
happen yeah don't go to shitstation.com
that's a whole other I've been there you
don't want to see what's on there yeah
yeah
foreign
[Music]
I was wondering
how do you feel about sitting in silence
not good man it's uncomfortable it's not
cool I don't think anybody really truly
likes sitting in silence sure but uh do
you know what else no one wants what's
that
to hear what the stranger next to them
is listening to because they're playing
something out loud like a jabroni and
aren't using earbuds oh my God no oops
no that's unacceptable okay or what
about listening to the YouTube videos
your kids are listening to in the back
seat that's the worst you don't want
that all of this pain and frustration
could be avoided if everyone would just
grab themselves a pair of raycons to
listen to their favorite album or go to
podcast which better be ours dude
totally absolutely raycon's everyday
earbuds look feel and sound better than
ever and they're half the price of the
other premium audio Brands I love mine
they're awesome that's a good thing so
you know what else I appreciate about
them
um the gel tips you know what I mean uh
they're very comfortable they're
comfortable they don't budge you know so
you feel like you can go on a run
that's the thing like I want to be able
to run around jump up and down hit a
golf ball I don't want my earbuds
falling out and uh with the raycons on
that's not gonna happen depending on
what you're up to you can switch between
noise isolation and awareness mode so
you have both total quiet or you can
hear the music but you can also hear
what's going on around you when I'm out
and about I like to keep one ear open
just in case
Rob Justice needs to step into a
situation yeah what have you been
listening to on your raycons lately uh
podcasts I listen to books on tape
myself uh well they call it books on
tape there's no more tape anymore music
I like music I like music a lot what
kind of music you listen to these days
oh man I've been listening to a lot of
like Bernard Hermann scores so he like
scored like uh vertigo and all these
Hitchcock movies Taxi Driver and like
what's going on oh man that guy's and
how's that sound on the raycons oh like
you're in the movie yeah yeah
um anyway
funny
code sunny today to get 15 off your acon
order that's code sunny at byracon.com
Sunny to score 15 off that's right by
raycon raycon is spelled
r-a-y-c-o-n.com slash Sunny code
Sunny
[Music]
I'm not always a great Storyteller I
will fully admit because I get bogged
down well only because you didn't have a
great story
even when I do though that story was my
Tesla was in a parking garage I couldn't
start it and it pissed me off yeah yeah
which ultimately isn't
his French lady you know well that's Rob
or some guy at the hamburger store yeah
yeah yeah I'm deciding whether to get
his double bats out I know it's a better
story 100 no 100 you're right and I
debated not even telling the story
because I was like I don't know this but
then I was like you know what I'll just
do it and if it's not good we'll just
cut that I'll tell you what is a good
story
uh sweet D has a heart attack it is yes
it is a great story it is a good story
um so we did we did the who's more
healthier thing in honor of this uh
episode but we still have not talked
about the actual episode which uh I feel
like I've heard multiple people say this
is one that they point to when they try
to get their friends into the show like
I feel like this is one of those ones
that people it's classic yeah kind of go
back to it's interesting because Danny's
story is so weird in this one like
Dennis story is a weird like direct
let's do one flew of the Cuckoo's Nest
and put him in like a literal One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest situation even
had the actor write this the sun yes
Chief Tim Sampson Tim Sampson well Tim
Simpson was the guy in Cuckoo's Nest no
will Sampson was the one in in Cuckoo's
Nest will Sampson played Chief in
Cougar's nest and we had a son yeah we
had his son Tim Sampson played the chief
in uh in our episode of sweet D has a
heart attack one was an oscar-winning uh
film and the other one was an episode of
uh Emmy nominated
an Emmy nominated uh half hour
well it's a half hour sitcom of of an
Emmy nominated television show yeah oh
first on coordination
well I mean stunts he threw that thing
through the window and that's a stunt
yeah so so and then Danny like climbed
the fence at the end of the thing and he
really was just kind of climbing and
stuck and we just rolled credits over
and then she's really kind of fun it was
great yeah we were like we and I think
we knew we might roll credits over it so
we're like just keep going just go as
far as you can go and we'll just keep
rolling on it and sure enough yeah and
we played was that the song from that
song sounds like it I think that's from
Cuckoo's Nest I think we actually it is
it is right yeah um because they're
playing a saw that's a song which you
know if people don't know you can bend a
saw like a right and take a violin bow
and how do you know that that's what
that is you can just tell about the
sound it's just such a specific noise
yeah
yeah I think I remember us looking that
up at the time
that sounds like a theremin yeah it's a
weird those are also [ __ ] cool I
would love to have a theorem I I see
people playing the theremin I'm like oh
I want to do that that theremin is an
amazing thing where it's like an
electric wave and you just move your
hand through the wave and it changes the
tone to the wave how much is a theremin
I'm gonna get let's get one for this
sure can we get let's get a theremin and
let's just let's just play with it
because I think people think theremins
are cool we'll get a cool theremin we're
gonna get there can we get a saw let's
get a song Let's get a saw and a bow any
of us okay make a noise on it this uh
this episode has the most popular meme
from our television show and it's true
yes I mean the storyline right you're in
my storyline in the mail room is and you
know at the office and with the day bow
bow is so funny so good
also great directing by Matt shackman
too I remember they built those shafts
for the letters to drop down yeah and we
had someone just offset dumping ladders
constantly and it really like as the
tension and the flow of it was that his
idea oh yeah
that was shackman's ideas coming down
all the time yeah yeah and then um the
you know Rob Roselle's monologue that he
wrote is amazing
take a look at this Jesus Christ that
right there is the mail now let's talk
about the mail can we talk about the
mail please mark I'm dying to talk about
the mail for you all day okay
a lot of people ask me if Pepe Silvia
was supposed to be Pennsylvania which I
don't believe it was I don't no in fact
I should ask Rosella by the way it also
wasn't supposed to be Pepe Silvia
do you remember that was it Silva or
something it was Pepe Silva it was a
Silva yes and Charlie you just kept
saying Pepe Silvia yeah so they chant
and so we just they had to change the
stuff on this yeah and I remember
Charlie just going just make it Sylvia
because that's what I keep saying and so
they changed it up oh my God that's
right it was Pepe Silva it was yeah but
Sylvia just kind of yeah balled off the
tongue better but no it's not a
reference to Pennsylvania but I like
that theory so I like that so it was
very scripted then that monologue was it
yeah I mean I was probably adding some
flourishes but only because of the speed
at which we move you know sometimes it's
hard to memorize
something that big because we're just
you know we're shooting 12 Pages a day
and producing and all this stuff so I
probably was like
I don't know I think I remember I had
enough time to just really work that so
you did I had it down you had it
memorized I mean I remember that you
know what's really weird is that you
know obviously the meme of me smoking
and pointing at the board with Pepe
Sylvia and all the strings you know is
used all the time for someone who's
crazy but like we didn't invent the
string board thing that had been around
in tons of movies and things now do they
really do that in at the FBI and over at
the police station are they doing that
yeah
they probably replaced it with
technology now and there's probably some
guy it's like I can't get it I can't get
the string in yeah where what what's
wrong with the string
they work fine
wandering the streets now because we
can't use the string because I can't get
the string afterwards
the CSI app I've got the CSI app and
it's supposed to happen there's no Wi-Fi
in this parking garage and this is where
the murder took place and I can't and
the string to go to the string yeah Will
somebody go to the yarn store and just
get some yarn like well let me sort this
app out because all we need is no this
is easier this is easier I'm telling you
this is easier do you ever seem like it
would have been fun to have been a
detective yes oh yeah yeah
most people fantasize about like oh it'd
be really fun to soft crowd I'm sure
it's but well it's Grizzly it's Grizzly
and yeah it's not like the the
detectives that I talked to one
specifically who was the father of a
friend of mine in high school he said uh
I was like well it's fascinating to be a
detective he's like it's the husband the
ex-husband the brother the boyfriend
until it is
it is those are the people that are
committing almost all of the crimes yeah
sure sorry so husband husband ex-husband
boyfriend ex-boyfriend sometimes brother
I ask you Charlie if you think you can
remember any of the speech that classic
speech do you think you still have it
memorized could you do something yeah
let's talk about the minute you want to
talk about the mail I'm dying to talk
about the mail uh that's the top but
this name keeps coming up Pepe Silvia
Pepe Sylvia
yeah yeah yeah that's why I marched down
the office I think Carolyn HR yeah
yeah it really is man and then and then
culminating in the whole Barney thing is
just terrific man like I don't know who
that actor was that we got to play
Barney but he just had a presence he did
it great but then your storyline's
amazing too the whole thing where you go
in to work out and then you're arguing
with the guy you go out to your car the
audience doesn't know what's going on
you grab something you come back in and
you put Steve Winwood in his CD player
spin class come on a bunch of hamsters
on a wheel yeah I'm gonna ride a bike
hard I'm gonna ride a bike fast and oh
yeah I'm not gonna go anywhere yeah and
then when I walk out I'm gonna put a
bunch of metal onto a metal bar and lift
that metal over and over like a metal
jerk you know I gotta be honest with you
I feel like these supplements are doing
a great job on their own you know what I
mean I've got tons of energy my heart
rate's up things are going great
absolutely I feel good too look how
vascular I am look at how my veins are
popping [ __ ] yeah I look good and I feel
good I feel good too apart from the
recent bouts of explosive diarrhea oh
I've been having diarrhea oh God all
over the place really well you know what
that is that's probably your body
flushing out all the toxins you think so
I do think so yeah yeah I on the other
hand have not taken a [ __ ] in days days
no it's good my body's working at 100
efficiency yeah my body is absorbing
every single nutrient and it's not
wasting a single thing
that guy who plays the spin instructor
nailed it yeah yeah
oh yeah I have his name oh you do yeah
let's call let's call him Dan so Gordon
please
and then when you come back in that's a
gift for you bumblebee right
now that was not scripted that was just
on the day he was dressed like a
bumblebee yes
and I don't even know that coach
dickenballs was coaching no coach
dickenballs was on the script either no
that was okay
I will say when Dennis and D like team
up I love those storylines when you guys
just like get on the same page about
something and you're like in total
agreement it's like it's just really fun
to watch there's a lot of good like
where the camera is aiding the joke as
well like that's a great one where you
because it's a runner yeah it's a one or
you don't know what's gonna happen the
other one where we just put put the
mirror down and then reveal that you've
got the collagen in your eye and your
eyes all swollen it's all droopy yeah
it's just a good like
[Music]
oh yeah that's in that scene too yeah no
I but I I do think like the the my
favorite storyline in the whole thing is
is the two of you guys
um you know I mean is this the scene of
you know you going into the office and
Dave like the whole bringing up of debao
Bao like which if you didn't grow up
watching those 80s movies it was in
multiple it was in multiple it was in
Ferris Bueller Ferris Bueller and Secret
of My Success and Secret of My Success
right right those those are the two that
I remember we made three movie
references in this episode three okay
which yeah yeah right
Secret of My Success Secret of My
Success and
it's the third one a big one
we just talked about it a beautiful mind
yeah that we yeah you reveal A Beautiful
Mind had come out around that time and
the idea that that he was seeing this
like person that didn't exist that movie
I don't think I finished that movie I
think I watched like an hour of it and I
was like
yeah he's smart
that'd be crazy I get it yeah we won't
talk about it too much but also that
because we're gonna have Michael not
none uh as a guest but the scene where
he interviews Mac and Charlie for the
job is okay so that scene was very very
short on the page yeah when you watch it
because the we've seen the outtakes of
it so many times and the outtakes are so
fun and then you see the actual scene
yourself and it's like it's a line yeah
and the I remember it being so much
longer but there's been a few moments
doing these re-watches where
yeah either the outtakes or our cut
scene were actually funnier than what is
in the show yeah but sometimes you can't
like
you know even though the outtakes are
funny you can't really be in that you
have to stop down the whole episode to
to do a bit and it really doesn't push
the story forward at all like it doesn't
progress the story in any way it doesn't
get you got you're not supposed to be
coming out of there hot because this guy
was giving you a hard time like no
nothing it didn't so you just had when
things the whole thing is that we'll
we'll do one job for half the pay and so
that's out yeah you don't even have to
pay us and then he's like well legally I
have to pay but minimum wage that's the
government salary yeah yeah I just
remember being so tickled by by Michael
Naughton sitting behind the the cameras
and just watching the whole thing and
just watching this guy it's always such
a pleasure when you work with somebody
who you feel like just gets it like just
gets what it is that not even to say
that other people who don't get it
aren't funny but people who get what I
mean is like people who get what it is
that we're doing and he just got it he
just got it right away played it totally
real
yet everything that came out of his
mouth was funny his timing was good did
we ever justify so that so much so that
we brought him back multiplying yeah did
we ever suggest that he that those are
the same people we know I don't think
the waiter no no no we never said no but
but we did talk about it and our
justification was there's no reason why
this guy couldn't have been working in
this office sure and then and then lost
that job and had to go back to his
waiting gig and then we did establish
that he I think he was uh trying to be
some other thing it might be amazing to
have to have Michael Naughton back but
not as the waiter character as the
character Foo worked in HR or who uh who
hired us that's a different person as a
different person and it turns out that
they're just different people maybe
they're maybe they're twins yes you know
and then like neither of them can see
the similarity they don't see it at all
yeah do you guys recognize that twin
yeah he never recognized the waiter but
he's not the guy that's really funny
that's really funny Charlie and I run
into to that guy and we're like oh hey
man you hired us at
[Laughter]
I'll write the twofer yeah yeah yeah
yeah I remember the waiters there like
what yeah and you are and you have a
twin and you would be
that's another thing I forgot about that
episode is that we've been fired but
we're still there you know yeah oh yeah
right yeah you established it like oh no
we were fired we've already been fired
we've already nailed them halfway to
Siberia that's what you say about the
pink slips yeah yeah I also like the
continued like bad advice like you need
to calm down have a cigarette and a cup
of coffee you need to calm down drink
more coffee yeah I've been drinking
coffee I also love when you are
delivering the mail in that scene and
you're making up those little rhymes for
everybody and you're like Mr White this
wife is not very bright
I think you improv that too I did improv
that yeah I don't think any of that was
in the script either no yeah that's
always fun oh that's that's you on the
other end of the phone call yeah when
you slip into the office and you're in
Johnson's office okay
yeah yeah this is Johnson yeah
where are you and why are you in my
office who's this
is Johnson oh
I thought you were in Orlando I am in
Orlando I'm trying to check my voicemail
a very funny from Rob like hanging up of
the phone very slowly
were you were you did you do like a
when we had established earlier in the
episode we were like oh well dude I
could
[Applause]
hey guys
um
what comes to your mind when you think
about the word versatility you know what
I mean because if it's not your workout
shorts chances are you're not working
out with fiori shorts okay or lounging
with Fiore they're performance-minded
apparel is perfect for running training
swimming and yoga but it's also perfect
for running errands or doing chores or
just sitting around your house on your
ass I'm going to read what needs to be
read
but I'm super into my Biore shorts
genuinely and if you find a pair that
can give you all those things that still
look great and B Next Level comfy my
friend that is capital V versatility if
you already are the most versatile and
comfortable workout clothes I've ever
owned and you know whichever letters
they do or do not put on their clothes
they offset 100 this is cool they offset
100 of their carbon and plastic
footprint which makes me very happy it's
true viori is an investment in your
happiness for our listeners they are
offering 20 off your first purchase get
yourself some of the most comfortable
and versatile clothing on the planet at
viore.com sunnypod that's
v-u-o-r-i.com slash Sunny paw not only
will you receive 20 off your first
purchase but enjoy free shipping uh on
any us orders over 75 and free returns
you know if it doesn't fit um go to
fiore.com Sunny pod and discover the
versatility of viori clothing
foreign
have you guys gotten your colonoscopies
no come on yeah your your bowel Flora
so does colon cancer yes yeah colon
cancer can do the same that'll [ __ ]
that'll [ __ ] with your Flora well but if
you've got the right floor you can you
can you can well here's the thing I mean
health is such a such a weird like okay
so you could have the best uh
cholesterol not the best blood pressure
or testosterone but the best cholesterol
um
and then you could be like
I don't know [ __ ] bit by a [ __ ]
mosquito with malaria and die in a week
you might be the healthiest
today
and then something might happen next
week and you're not you know like that
has nothing to do with your diet or your
exercise it could be like
environmental it could be accidental
well
I was talking to a uh a doctor who we
interviewed for uh our
documentary series uh welcome to wrexham
and she was talking about
she was talking about relationships and
she was talking about friendships and
she said that there have been major
studies uh and I'm going to choose to
believe her that suggests that the
greatest indicator of a long and healthy
life is not your cholesterol or your
blood pressure uh it is not obesity or
diabetes or anything like that it's
having friends I think you're right
I think you're 100 right and more
friends you have the longer you live and
also I would say like your diversity of
friends too because like
I consider everybody who helped me with
that whole Tesla situation a friend you
know what I mean um they're not people
that I would Google exchange numbers I
did yes
uh these are not people that I I
normally interact with because they're
not in the entertainment business so
most of the people that I talk to are in
the entertainment business or they go to
school with my kid or they're on my kids
soccer team like that's the extent of my
life because that's all I really have
room for you know what I mean but I
think that's unfortunate
I think that's really unfortunate I
really do because I really liked these
people
that they were wonderful your Tesla
friends your Tesla friends yeah yeah
it's my stranded car well depend
regardless of how I a healthy or
unhealthy I I am and we've established
that I'm the least healthy of the group
um although I fit into a range of of of
healthy uh-ish
um I'd just like to say I'm I'm happy
that I'm friends with you guys and with
you Megan and that I I like to believe
I'm going to live a very long life
because of it [ __ ] you
um all right well [ __ ] him right yeah go
[ __ ] yourself man [ __ ] yourself dude
that's really lame super [ __ ] lame
testosterone it shouldn't cause that all
this yes I've been enlightened by
Glenn's rich guy story
I truly am I was joking about being a
blade of grass on one of the most more
recent episodes but now I I truly am a a
blade of grass but soon that grass will
dry up and Harden again and I will break
congrassed eyes too and grass dies
quickly yeah quickly
it's gonna happen in about
six weeks when I ask you uh how much
you've hung out with your new friends
that you've whose numbers you've
exchanged and you're going to say zero
and then Charlie and I are going to rip
into you and you're absolutely yeah well
you're gonna get upset yeah no you're
you're absolutely right uh you're
absolutely right about that
um I I don't know if I'm gonna hang out
with Renee in security over at the DGA
but I tell you what next time I see him
next time I'm in the DJ building
I don't know if he wants a hug from me
that might be weird but if he wants to
go see Buddha at The Comedy Store yeah
you want to go see Sardar katama you're
gonna have to drive Renee because I
can't get my [ __ ] car because I made
the mistake yeah I did that again
uh anyway how are you Renee
um Renee was wonderful as was David the
other security guard that was helping me
out wonderful people Eddie the the
construction guy I can't remember my tow
truck operator he was a real character
can't remember his name he's driving me
crazy I was trying to think of that this
morning I was like damn it what was his
name so I really liked him but the
dispatcher's name was India
[Music]
that sounds on a joke uh hey Charlie
Chuckles
anyone out here live in a temple
any Temple dwellers
you know I had a guy come to my temple
the other day said uh he wants to put
all the uh all the lights on a Wi-Fi
I am like uh
yeah like well there's normally no point
in uh punchline because uh you know
that's uh that would equal happening
which is the same sadness and uh we
don't punch people uh I said who who
needs light I'm already enlightened nice
very good uh I'm here all week I'll be
here all week you won't be actually I
won't I'll be here but I'll also be at
the temple I can do that I'll be
everywhere and nowhere all at once
foreign
[Applause]